so I'm here today to encourage you to
think about New York City and not just
as one of humanity's greatest
achievements but is home to native
wildlife that are subject to a grand
evolutionary experiment so take this
forested hillsides in northern Manhattan
for example this is one of the last
areas left in the city where there's
clean spring water that's still seeping
out of the ground you could drink this
out of your hands who'd be okay
these tiny little areas of seeping water
contain huge populations of northern
dusky salamanders these guys were common
in the city maybe 60 years ago but now
they're just stuck on this single
hillside in a few places in Staten
Island not only do they suffer the
indignity of being stuck on this
hillside but we divided that hillside
into on two different occasions with
bridges crossing from the Bronx into
Manhattan but they're still there on
either side of the bridges where you see
the red arrows about 180 Street 167th
Street my lab has found that if you just
take a few seconds of DNA from
salamanders in those two locations you
can tell which side of the bridge they
came from we build this single piece of
infrastructure that's changed their
evolutionary history we can go study
these guys you know we just go to the
hillside we know where they are flip
over rocks that we can catch them there
are a lot of other things in New York
City though that are not that easy to
capture such as this guy coyote we
caught him on an automatic camera trap
somewhere in an undisclosed location but
I like to talk about it yet but they're
moving into New York City for the first
time they're very flexible intelligent
animals this is one of this year's pups
checking out one of our cameras and my
colleagues and I are very interested in
understanding how they're going to
spread through the area how they're
going to survive here and maybe even
thrive and they're probably coming to a
neighborhood near you if they're not
already there so there's some things
that are too fast we caught by hand we
can't pick them up on the camera so we
actually set out traps all around New
York City in the parks this is one of
our most common activity here's some of
my students and collaborators getting
the traps out ready and this guy we
catch in almost every forested area in
New York City this is the white-footed
Mouse this is not the mouse you find
running around your apartment this is a
native species been here long before
humans
and you find them in forests and meadows
were you because they're so common in
forested areas in the city we're using
them as a model to understand how
species are adapting to urban
environments so if you think back 400
years ago the five boroughs would have
been covered in forest and other types
of vegetation this mouse would have been
everywhere huge populations that showed
few genetic differences across the
landscape but if you look at the
situation today they're just stuck in
these little islands of four scattered
around the city just using 18 short
segments of DNA we can pretty much take
a mouse somebody could give us a mouse
not tell us where it was from and we
could determine what park it came from
that's how different they become you'll
notice in the middle of this colored
figure here there's some mixed up colors
there are a few parks in the city that
are still connected to each other with
strips of forest so that the mice can
run back and forth and spread their
genes so they don't become different but
that's throughout the city they're
mostly becoming different in the parks
all right so I'm telling you they're
different but what does that really mean
what's changing about their biology to
answer this question we're sequencing
thousands of genes from our city mice
and comparing those to thousands of
genes from the country mice so their
ancestors outside of New York City in
these big more wilderness areas now
genes are short segments of DNA that
code for amino acids and amino acids are
the building blocks of proteins now if a
single base pair changes in a gene you
can get a different amino acid which
will then change the shape and structure
of the protein if you change the
structure of a protein you often change
something about what it does in the
organism now if that change leads to a
longer life or more babies for a mouse
something evolution biologists call
fitness then that single base pair
change will spread quickly in an urban
population so this crazy figure is
actually called a Manhattan plot because
it kind of looks like a skyline and each
dot represents one gene and the higher
the dot is in the plot the more
different it is between city and country
mites the ones kind of at the tips of
the skyscrapers are the most different
especially those above the red line and
these genes encode for things like
immune response to disease there might
be more disease and very dense urban
populations metabolism how the mice use
energy and heavy-metal tolerance you
guys could probably predict that New
York City soils are
pretty contaminate with lead and
chromium and that sort of thing and our
hard work is really starting we're going
back into the wilds of New York City
parks following the lives of individual
mice and seeing exactly what these genes
are doing for them and I've encouraged
you guys to try to look at your parks in
a new way I'm not going to be the next
Charles Darwin but what you guys might
be so just keep your eyes open thank you
you